nach amerika fahren oder so was halt so
bis in die welt der content ja wenn ein
abendlicher mensch was wird zu machen
dadurch wird einfach weiter machen genau
ich jetzt mache hallöchen meine lieben
ungeheuer und bekommst du hero mit dem
crafter und wir gehen jetzt auf den
servern ist jemand drauf und haben mit
dieser lässt ich habe mit ob die bieter
als drauf und uslar städten aus als
unserer verbündeten stadt aber der krieg
ist jetzt vorbei siemens muss man ganz
kurz erklären was los mit dem krieg so
scheiße ich habe ein problem ist nichts
neues
ja okay leute moment bei mir ist ganz
schwaches bild
und jetzt wieder alles okay ich wusste
einfach kaputt
wir haben gedacht wir nehmen heute
zusammen auf welche sie man muss vor
produzieren und ich muss mein haus ein
bisschen weiter bauen und ich habe ich
schon keine folge ich hab gestern
verpackt was hochzuladen die ist das und
ich baue gerade einfach normal im haus
rum deswegen können wir nebenbei auf ein
paar aus dem sachen geklaut habe getötet
zürich deswegen haben wir gedacht wir
gehen dabei einfach aufs ein paar
twitter fragen ein die ihr uns ja
einfach senden konnte unter dem hashtag
unbekannt und cool wie nichts grünen
weil sie echt an um gekonnt er wirklich
drauf ich geb dir wieder auf die sachen
zurück wir haben ja noch was vor heute
zusammen so warm ist kann was zusammen
machen was ich jetzt gemacht hätte wäre
ich finde richtig richtig schöne rote
bäume eigentlich ne aber die sind ich
finde die mega kaka einfach nur ich find
die richtig eklig eure sind richtig geil
aber eher bei uns sind auch die stämme
ausgetauscht worden bei uns war vorher
ihre stimme in richtung gerüchte mit und
ihr könnt auch die stimme austausch
hatten wir auch gedacht dass wir auch
einfach die stämme austauschen
nur ich weiß nicht wie mache ich das
dann mit diesem komischen thema das ich
nie einen ganzen baum kaputt machen du
musst aber es schleichen
also hilft und dann probieren
mainz funktioniert ja keine ahnung hast
du denn für ideen was wir machen wir
können ja irgendwie was bei dir im
freizeitpark bauen habt ihr gläubig oder
oder können auf tour gehen
die welt egal ich hätte sonst nichts vor
mit dunklem holz nicht naja
mit diesem hätten besser auf jeden fall
als vorher aber sonst eigentlich immer
noch würde ich jetzt nicht so gern drauf
abschießen wollen wir direkt mit einer
frage staaten oder willst du debitor ist
die sache wieder geben weil dann brauche
ich erst noch ein bisschen die stadt
nicht so lange gesucht die sache heute
hashtag ungekannter sind ein paar gute
sachen angekommen dass man ab werk
arbeite offen okay okay die ich jetzt
beantwortet nein abwechslung einer die
wir einfach so wie ihr leben abwechselnd
vorher genommen
die sachen einfach nicht schätze was
habe ich denn hier habt ihr eigentlich
privat auch noch zeit etwas zu zocken
oder zog den nur für aufnehmen
zu anfang also ich sage ich vereinfache
h
ich bin privat auch öfters mal wow oder
andere sachen
also ich wie auch privat das war heute
vormittag und habe nicht viel weiter
umstritten
aber sonst geht eigentlich jeder seine
ausbeute zeit seit ihr was heißt ein
umzugsstress seit dieser zeit zu einem
sachen suchen oder seid ihr schon
mittendrin im umzug oder studierten drin
wir sind schon mittendrin
wir haben jetzt internet dort habe ich
gelesen dass der dafür mülheimer leitung
hatte den kac mlm bild upload bis sind
schon richtig stellt man damit seinen
normalen hero card hoch beispielsweise
10 15 minuten maximal oha ich brauche
einfach drei stunden bei der rente
ich finde einfach die sachen für die
mieter nicht ich finde meine
steinplatten einfach nicht also ja was
ich sagen können was soll bleibt die
frage noch mal ach so ja zurzeit ehrlich
gesagt nicht aber auch nur zahl damals
was auch so dass der nebenher noch so
alles möglich
mal das gespielt habe dann habe ich mehr
darf gespielt
richtig weil ich ein richtiger spieler
halt aber zurzeit ist es halt wirklich
somit mit abiturvorbereitung geht jetzt
los und auch alles mögliche nach
studienplatz gucken und so was alles man
hat die sache das schön
damit wird das alles natürlich mega
stressig und weil ich auch für die ganze
kette lernen mussten als möglich ist
hier nicht von alleine
und ja nach wegen zur zeit ist nicht so
will
aber damals hatte ich echt zweifel aber
jetzt nicht mehr
aber damals ja ich hab 43 stone kacke
gefunden sports einen schönen weg weil
er meinte ich soll sozial werden in der
stadt deswegen jetzt mal ich möchte auch
eigentlich als könig kandidieren
deswegen mussten wir einen tollen
parteinamen überlegen wenn da etwas biss
könne es auch schreiben sie mal hü
letzte frage raussuchen oder oder
so rissen was würdet ihr machen wenn ihr
einen und euro gewinnen wird xxxx einem
einem eine million euro seine 100
verstanden oder auch kraß 100 euro
scheine wert von 8000 euro gewinnt 100
jahre leben ja was machen soll ich
anfangen weil sie nicht zuerst was will
ich machen
was ist richtig doofe frage weil für
mich eigentlich geld nicht so viel
bedeutet im leben natürlich geld ist die
währung geht es da fand ich eine szene
empfehlen aber irgendwie ich weiß nicht
ob ich werde damit nicht glücklich aber
dass die frage ist ja blick nicht ob wir
glücklich werden sondern was wir machen
würden
und ich glaube ich würde auf jeden fall
war spenden
ok damit ich so gegen den ganzen strom
von den ganzen spaß hieß gehe weil wir
nicht da so eine paris hilton serie
millionen er abt und einfach das alles
verdreht und drogen und alles mögliche
wie ich das nicht so geil so ein event
auf jeden fall
und was soll ich sonst machen ich glaube
ich würde mir so ein paar träume
erfüllen so irgendwie mal nach amerika
fahren oder so was halt so ein bisschen
die welt der kontinent ja wenn ein
abendlicher mensch was wird zu machen
glaube ich wird einfach weiter machen
genau und jetzt mache einfach jolo mode
nicht ob ich das ändern würde das gerät
jetzt alles irgendwie ein bisschen
asymmetrisch bei mir
hayes brauchen fans eigentlich immer
noch bei euch in stat pink doch ja dann
könnten wir die hammer langsam aus
unserer stadt verbannen sagte kempf mal
angedeutet aber das müssen wir unsere
königin fragen
da kann ich am ende der folge meinem
eine magische miesmuschel app auspacken
was die dazu sagt wie die verbannen
sollen oder nicht weil die adresse zu
entscheiden werde wenn ich nett oder
leute ja du dir innerhalb dieser spricht
sei nie so schweiz ich bin daran gewöhnt
als ich weiß nicht was dort im jahr gott
da ist die bito irgendwo hier kann ich
zu den sachen wieder haben töte ihn
nein nein nein na ja wenn man zur zeit
alle frieden ins frieden auch komisch
damals also das war auch kacke wenn man
so gesehen also drei leute sonst aber
nein ich gehe lieber man nicht drauf
blabla vor allem megaprojekt meine
einfach aufgehen gucken wir es ist dann
vielleicht wieder runter
aber ihr geht darf man das ja nicht wo
mein keyboard gerade eine feder
ausgekannt tech capital inc hudbay adis
braun oder schlicht gut kenne viele
frauen ist die farbe der recht beruht
npd egal
seine frage raussuchen hast du schon ein
raus musste
hattest du die eine million frage ich
habe die einen fall wie ein wie eure
frage na ja dann bist du
was machen schimpfwörter so anders als
andere wörter bedeutung da wir traurig
aber wenn man da mal mehr darüber
nachdenken sondern wort wie die oat ist
jetzt nicht so was wie [ __ ] oder
der sohn einer [ __ ] bist sondern idiot
ist einfach ein ganz normales wort
genauso wie [ __ ] oder so wir sind
ganz normale wörter da muss man aber
allgemeinen die sprachwissenschaft
reingehen wo ich mein abitur auf
wahrscheinlich drüber schreiben werde
warum sind wörter wie wörter sind das
ist die frage
ein ohne scheiß warum heißt die banane
bananen und warum heißt die banane apfel
oder umgekehrt wenn sie also jemand
genannt hat vielleicht wer hat wer hat
sie dann benannt
der detektor vielleicht herberner ja es
gibt auch immer leute also etwa bei
natürlich nicht
ja klar wenn einer irgendwie die einheit
newton oder irgendwie sowas ist klar
oder aldi aber ich weiß nicht
das ist alles so ich hab keine ahnung
ich weiß nicht wie ich das weiterbauen
soll ich will auf jeden fall vier häuser
hier den baum
man sieht jetzt alles sehr uncool
zurzeit aus ok muss man helfen komm zu
mir dann zeige ich was ich baue okay
aber die bitterste bei mir
er beobachtet mein haus erstmal shift
loslassen ist mein pferd ich mein baum
ich kann mein baum rumhacken
hey ich dachte eigentlich hätten walkers
wort aber ich habe bock aufs wort aber
da steht auch was wohl dran aber dass
kaká ins hilflos berlin eine scheiße ist
nicht diese teilten sich brille
portieren kann dann eben doch jj kann
das nicht simon ja ich hatte so ein
hübscher ich hänge an der decke wie
komme ich darunter wechselte wenig musik
machen
gegen 500 weggerückt wie sein kölner
spiels geht das oben auch ein wenig oder
richtig schwerer brocken
er hat mit mir etwas mehr gerechnet er
dachte ich vorab in den hinterhalt in
der falle
aber da ist nicht gerne besuchen kommen
ich weiß ich hab zwei zusatz herzen dass
jetzt auch nicht so das größte aber ich
habe heftig verzauberte schwert und
einer heftigen kristlbauer also das
alles drauf was geht und ich hab das
geld aber wo auch ganz gut verzaubert
ich okay ich brauche diese extra herzen
da bis jetzt mal meine pharma und
verzaubert die auch mal ein bisschen
beim haus um ein komplettes versucht
also ich hab mich selbst gezeigt was du
bist jetzt gebaut ist das einfach mal so
zeigen okay man heute sind schwierige
folge ja von mir kommt zu mir dann zeig
ich's dir wenn der nächste folge oder so
wenn man mal erkundungstour machen
man packt hier noch an breaking und
protection drauf und hier kommt noch
mehr kann ich gar nicht drauf packen
naja ok gut
mohammed die frist um nicht wieder so
mega schnell nein die leute doch die bei
scannern sieht man bis zu ruhig ich habe
dinge konzentriert euch vielleicht noch
eine frage vor
er muss doch nicht beantwortet das waren
meine frage was nach schimpfwörter
besonders damals keine antwort war meine
bedeutung
ja ja schimpfwörter machen für mich
besonders dass die man hat es hat sich
als so eingeprägt dass diese wörter böse
sind ja genau wie einfach man damit
vielleicht wird dann haben die negativ
negative einfach wenn man damit bereitet
wird dann haben die negativ jetzt weiß
schön die partie was lowered flucht los
schreibt wird der leyen nein das war
falsche frage hier ist es aufschreibt
was sagt ihr zur situation michael
schumacher und interessiert ihr euch für
autos wenn ja was genau
ok es gut jetzt ich rate ich mich
interessiert ihr euch für autos wenn ja
was genau das was man zu sein
ich freue mich umso öfter autos also ich
nämlich gerade für autos nämlich jetzt
wohnung nach köln zieht willst du den
auto holen
das ist 1 auto das ist also erst mal
cool dass für den autoren welt aber da
ist das nicht irgendwie unsinnig in der
stadt weiter weg aber ich will meine
familie zurück frau dann ist will ich ja
bei mir ist also erst michael schumacher
ist mit mich schon machen aber ich sage
ja also wie man eine traurige sache war
ist auf jeden fall super lieber mensch
gewesen ist er auf jeden fall mit meiner
kindheit zu tun gehabt in europa mal von
1 guckt und natürlich situation dass da
so was passiert ist uns so aber es ist
halt einfach der typ ist einfach muss
einfach sagen und adrenalin junkie
danke also nicht negativ gemeint sondern
er braucht einfach dieses risiko weil er
einem kerl sein leben lang ein risiko
sachen gemacht und ich habe das gefühl
er braucht es so richtig krass
ich finde ich ein bisschen
verantwortungslos gegenüber weil er
hatte familie hat mit kind und so hat
richtig viel geld müsste in seinem leben
eigentlich wieder sich sorgen machen was
und dann macht der sonne in hand kann
man also so eine scheiße fährt auf einem
feldweg ab und zu wenn das stimmt hat
auf jeden fall ja und dann muss ich
sagen bestätigt auch mal sowas macht
nicht aber nichtsdestotrotz natürlich
trotzdem und deswegen also ich hoffe
natürlich mit dem bald wieder gut gehen
so also ich hoffe es klappt so ich weiß
es nicht genau
wir standen letztes lied bekomme er ist
jetzt wieder in der aufwachphase also
ich also heute wurde da glaube ich aus
dem koma geholt habe ich heute gelesen
doch einfach mal das ist der ist es halt
alles schafft so aber ist der verschleiß
sache so aber das ist halt einfach da
kann nicht sieht man nur zustimmen
das habe ich mich auch immer gesagt egal
ob auch wenn es sonntag übels und so es
ist wirklich seine schulter kann jetzt
die skipiste nichts für wenn er ist ja
von der piste irgendwie abgefahren oder
so und ist abseits der piste gefahren
dann ist man ja selbst schuld wenn man
abseits dieser abgespeckten des
abgesteckten bereich star fährt wenn man
einen unfall baut
also ich muss sagen ich hatte auch viel
mit michael schumacher so zu tun mehr
oder weniger weil er halt auch bei jener
kinder ich hab ja auch oft formel 1
geguckt und so deswegen ja ich weiss
nicht also es ist schon irgendwie als
das gehört aber ich mir sogar zum mars
michael schumacher skiunfall ließ das
schon krass aber es ist ja schön dass es
sie mittlerweile besser geht aber man
muss echt sagen so leid es mir tut es
war wirklich echt seine schuld und naja
also aber auch heftig was das für wellen
geschlagen hat also dass da wirklich
die französische presse hatte dass ihr
überall in den medien
die hatten ja gar keine andere story
mehr wusste ich gar nicht dass er so
bekannt war da überhaupt ja wohl eins
der weltweit und thema
aber ja sonst würde ich sagen es war
halt seine schuldner aber ich will es
hier nicht zu den spielen so der blogger
du bist ja so viel denkt aber seine
familie ja natürlich aber es war man
muss einfach sagen es war seine schuld
aber ist natürlich traurig dass es so
passiert ist aber es gut dass ihm besser
geht das sehe ich genauso
frage war was interessiert für autos so
ich habe die satire die stars wird mir
gerne einen war ein einen wagen holen
und zwar einen also mai noch nicht bald
selber da war es noch nicht richtig
lange bis wir nachholen weil ich halt
einfach einfach an ist einfach ein
tolles auto ein vw scirocco
das ist so der kostet 25.000 oder sonne
ja aber ich bin kein neuer bahnhof um
die 10.000 euro willst du dann diese
variante mit 220 ps oder oder welcher
muss ich die schnellste aber ich möchte
meinen grün
denn egal aber hätte grün sein
der scirocco also ich gucke also zeit
auch nach auto weil die stars ich 18 und
ich fahre gern auto und blabla also
eindruck hatte ich auch gedacht der ist
auf meiner engeren auswahl
nicht alle autos ich mir bisher so
ausgeguckt habe also ich habe ein
bisschen ein mini paceman bmw 118
und den scirocco rausgesucht und die
sind halt alles benziner deshalb mega
teuer zu finanzieren vor allem die
versicherung deswegen weil das ja immer
bei solchen autos sind es gibt ja immer
diese unfallrate dem nachmieter die
versicherung dann ich sag mal auf ihr
aufgetragen teurer und zwar wenn man
sich so ein golf gti kauft denkt man
erst mal sowie oder kostet weniger als
der scirocco chillig wo ich mit denen
man aber die versicherung ist circa
doppelt so teuer weil damit doppelt so
viele unfälle gebaut werden und deswegen
ist die versicherung hat dementsprechend
teuer das kann man sich ja leicht
erklären
deswegen muss halt nach alben gucken
beim auto deshalb nicht nur so auf das
auto kosten zu viel blabla
den hole ich mir mal seien es halt auch
der verbraucher alles mögliche deswegen
mittlerweile kann man sich eigentlich
durch die kreditmöglichkeiten in
deutschland jeder könnte sich nahezu
fast jeder
jeder kann sie teure schnelles auto
holen nur das ganze auf dauer zu
finanzieren deshalb mega schwer
also irgendwie wegen versicherungen
wegen tüv alles mögliche aber etliche
rocker von so 2010 oder 2009 + aufwärts
also bis jetzt die etwas höheren wert
auf dem automarkt fehle echt schön so
der zum coupé und ich finde so
dreitürige sowieso schöner als so
wickelt großartig den gefechten der vor
allem wenn du dann immer hin- und
herpendeln willst du jetzt auch ganz gut
und kann zum stadtverkehr gebrauchen
blabla vor allem der hat doch glaube ich
start-stopp also dass der halt stopp wer
stehen bleibt das ganz gut für
stadtverkehr
ich weiß eigentlich habe ich mir
einholen soll bei welcher halt direkt
nach dem nach dem abi möchte ich halt
studieren und wahrscheinlich halt
entweder in köln düsseldorf oder hamburg
und da sind halt alles so städte wo man
eigentlich mit strass man alles
erreichen kann und auch günstiger ist
deswegen bin ich mir da nicht so sicher
doch es passt doch perfekt mit den
häusern ja schön leute an die die jetzt
gucken hier kamen vier tolle heute
spielt mal ganz gesagt um online haben
90 minuten die polycom vier tolle häuser
hin
wir können uns gegenseitig zeigen
wir machen wir dann machen sie es denn
in den nächsten aufnahme machen noch
eine folge und dann wenn ihr weiter
sehen wollt wie das ganze bei mir
aussieht oder wie das ganze bei simon
aussieht dann in verschiedenen folge an
oder einfach bei uns verschieden jetzt
wieder auf hohe kräfte findet man ja
auch in der schreibe unterstützt wie man
nicht die man nicht versteht
der ist okay 25 minuten schon jetzt ist
die schnell mit ihm geredet werden auch
die nächste folge weit über themen reden
also wenn ihr unsere twitter folgt man
könnte ja auch mal mitbestimmen einfach
rum gespielt und dadurch sagen wenn sich
das wetter bis zum nächsten und schaut